Speaker 1: A number of you sent me a clip
of Congresswoman Cori Bush claiming that red
states have higher rates of murder and higher
rates of gun deaths.
And that is absolutely true.
And I'm going to go over some of the data
with you.
Now, this is relevant because the story that
the right loves to tell is how red states
are safer and red cities are safer.
And blue states and blue cities run by Democrats
are just riddled with crime and they're dangerous.
And that's really where all of the violence
is.
Let's first listen to what Cori Bush said.
Then we're going to look at some of this data
in 2020.
Speaker 3: Per capita murder rates were 40%
higher in states won by Donald Trump than
those won by Joe Biden.
Nine of the ten states with the highest gun
mortality rates, including my state of Missouri,
are red states.
Mr. Wilcox.
First of all, thank you for your strong, well
informed advocacy.
I want to build on Mr. Natalie's question.
Can you explain how the armed pipeline and
Republican laws.
A gun laws disproportionately harm black and
brown communities?
Speaker 1: Yes.
Speaker 2: Ranking Member And thank you for
the question.
Speaker 1: As as you stated, what we see pretty
clearly from examining.
Speaker 2: Gun laws and looking at rates of
gun violence is states with stronger gun laws
see less gun violence.
Speaker 1: Why is that?
It's because it's too.
Speaker 2: Easy for guns to be illegally diverted
from legal commerce, responsible, law abiding
citizens into gun trafficking channels.
What are the ways that that happens?
No.
Background check.
Gun sales.
Straw purchasing.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So now they go into a number of the ways in
which we could strengthen gun laws.
But so is this the truth?
You know, anecdotally, we keep hearing frequently
now, when Republicans talk about New York
City, the accurate statement that the violence
rate or the violent crime rate is higher in
Oklahoma City than it is in New York City,
Oklahoma City, a red city in a red state compared
to New York City, a blue city in a blue state.
But this is actually a bigger trend.
So let's look at a couple of different things.
If you look at the 2020 homicide rate and
if you're looking, there's a graph here where
you have states with the highest homicide
rates at the top right hour and lower homicide
rates as you go down to the bottom left, you
see that the states with the highest homicide
rates are Mississippi, Louisiana, Alabama,
Missouri, Arkansas, South Carolina, Tennessee,
Maryland, Illinois, New Mexico, Georgia.
You have this gradient wherein the homicide
rates are notably higher in red states.
You then go to firearms mortality and you
see a very similar story.
The highest death rate from firearms is Mississippi,
Louisiana, Wyoming, Missouri, Alabama, Alaska,
blue state of New Mexico, followed by Arkansas.
South Carolina.
Tennessee.
Montana.
Oklahoma.
Kentucky.
West Virginia.
Georgia.
Idaho.
Indiana.
Nevada.
Kansas.
Finally getting to Arizona.
Okay, So there is no doubt whatsoever that
that is the truth.
It doesn't matter how you slice and dice the
state numbers.
Now, how would the right react to this?
Well, one of the things that the right says
when presented with this information, one
of the things they say is the numbers aren't
true.
It's fake news.
We can't believe it.
It's all nonsense.
You made that up.
Okay.
Well, if you can get them to acknowledge these
numbers, they will often say, well, but the
crimes are mostly in the cities within those
states which are blue.
Now, that's not actually true.
It is true, as a general rule that people
on the left in the United States are more
likely to live in urban areas and people on
the right are more likely to choose to live
rurally and suburban.
It's sort of a mix depending on the states
that you're in.
That is absolutely true.
But in general, rates of crime can follow
where people are closer together.
But by looking at rates, we actually account
for that.
And there have been studies done that say,
okay, fine, you can look at these cities if
you want, and there are very high numbers
of crimes because of the number of people.
But you can chart, these are very large rural
areas that cross many states on a map.
And as far as rates of crimes go, they are
still very high in those rural areas.
It's just that the absolute numbers are lower
because there are fewer people.
But the truth is, if we want to be more serious
about this, there is no one answer to this.
Is it true that red states on average having
more relaxed gun laws increases gun deaths?
Yes, it is true.
And also it is true that if you live in Chicago,
which is a blue city and a blue state which
has strict gun laws, you can very easily drive
40 minutes over into Indiana or what is it
like 55, 60 minutes into Wisconsin, potentially
states with more relaxed gun laws.
So it it's everything is shades of gray.
The gun accessibility is a factor, but it
also impacts blue states that are in proximity
to red states.
Poverty is a major factor.
Poverty is higher in red states.
Education is a factor.
Education is worse in red states.
Cultural attitudes towards using guns to solve
problems.
I don't have data on what the differences
are between blue and red states on that, but
it is a factor in.
If you had states where culturally it's considered
more appropriate to fight to use physical
violence or to use guns to resolve interpersonal
problems, well, that's going to be a factor
for sure.
Infrastructure and economic opportunity, which
we know is lower in red states.
GDP per capita, lower in red states.
All of these elements are fact.
And many of them actually are sort of a feedback
loop where some cause others and in turn the
worsening of those others comes back and worsens
the initial causes.
Proximate and ultimate causes are definitely
something that needs to be considered.
But the numbers really don't lie.
It really is the case that gun mortality rates
remember, rate accounts for population, the
rates of gun mortality on average higher in
red states, the murder rate on average, higher
in red states.
They don't like to admit it.
When they do, they find some other way to
blame the left.
But this is the reality in which we live